be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly in 2010 as part of their Marvel
Adventures line a series of stories
geared towards younger children Marvel
gave us a retelling of the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline where Thanos had
wiped out half the life in the universe
we travel now to the Baxter building to
what's left of the Fantastic Four with
Susan storm and Ben Grimm as they meet
with a handful of superheroes and try to
figure out what next so here's what we
know yesterday morning
48 to 52 percent of the world's
population just vanished civilians
heroes villains friends family what we
don't know is why not yet but we think
we know where to start looking the
Baxter building is home to some of the
most sensitive comic monitoring
equipment in the solar system we use it
to keep tabs on chatter from the Kree
the scrolls that kind of thing
yesterday we picked up a mass of
superluminal wave of space-time passing
over the earth at the exact moment of
the disappearances we don't think that's
a coincidence the equipment was able to
track the origin of this wave to within
a few light-years of the galactic core I
don't have to tell any of you what it's
like to be out there we need answers we
need them now and we plan to find them
by sending a team to investigate this
thing at its source um excuse me
universal woman to the core the Milky
Way galaxy that's like millions of miles
away
a little over 235 quadrillion G that's
all and then would undo whatever was
done in short yes we chose a small team
with a wide range of abilities that'll
cover as many bases as possible without
leaving us short-handed back here on
earth
miss Marvel we'd like you to be the team
leader your powers shield background and
familiarity with space travel will prove
invaluable spider-man I know this is a
lot to ask of someone with a curfew but
we need you is our chief scientist I'm
going into space Hulk will provide all
smash um then lastly Wolverine because
he's on every superhero team sounds
exhausting no wonder you're always so
cranky and girl how the heck are we
going to send anyone a million
quadrillion miles away we actually have
a pretty novel solution to them behold
the grim visage of Doctor Doom get em BA
close in we've got a mountain of them
children fools that really hurt
yeah yeah it did you should do that
thing where you wreck him like with the
robot
I was trying to I guess we should get up
huh
yeah yeah we should think we can get
away with pertaining to be knocked out
nope how do you want to do this without
your help
Oh smash metal man face wrong all avoid
the smash train a trifle a little hand
says it's clobberin time quite
predictable mr. doom incidentally you
just supercharged my force fields power
matrix with the energy of your attack
which I shall now amplify and redirect
behold
servus a lesson in the futility of
opposing doom you haven't won yet doom
whatever you're planning people stop you
stop me you could no more defeat doom
than you could save your loved ones from
disappearing before your eyes what do
you suppose your husband was trying to
say to you in those final moments Susan
had his intellect second-rate as it is
already formulated the very solution you
and your pitiful band of survivors
struggled to find boom if you did
anything to read and Johnny
I'll make power out of you your threat
is both ridiculous and meaningless but I
played no part in their disappearances
you expect us to believe you if I could
rid myself of the accursed Fantastic
Four what I have stopped at two of you
furthermore if I kept any of you
wouldn't it have been Richard to better
torment him by mixing his efforts to
find his beloved family you're not
listening to this are you Susie
he has a point Ben but so do you do it
would be much easier to trust if you
released us if you can keep your
trigger-happy folks for attacking me
again you attacked us you will know when
doom Dane's to attack you no all I did
was expertly defend myself from a
pathetic series of clumsy attacks what
about the exploding wall and all that
behold the grim visage of doom and and
you blew up a wall yes that is how doom
enters a room how do you do it uh
through the door and sometimes the
window but that is a count the door like
a peasant